see anything in there there's nothing in  this poorly lit location well except  this garbage that's not garbage that's  the iconic item that the character used  once I thought he was just a minute who  goes there holy cow it's the iconic  character I haven't been called that in  a long time was this yours ah yes the  Beloved paper towels that I used in a  scene for like one second are you like  like okay or what I'm not like what you  expected would happen after 30 years  that's the point that's the idea I'll do  the thing I'll do the thing all right  okay I know you're like a big fan of me  but this other guy is is more cynical so  he'll probably take my place when I die  what  hi everyone